(audience clapping)
- Welcome back y'all.
It's Christmas and across America
there are countless charities
working hard to provide holiday
magic for those in need.
We've even met a number of them this week,
well my next guests are
part of that generosity.
But instead of giving toys or food
they do something different,
they provide Christmas trees.
For many people it's the
most important gift of all.
Let's welcome David and Michelle.
Y'all give it up!
(audience claps and cheers)
So thank you so much
for being on the show,
I'm very excited to have you here.
But Michelle this all started,
was it from a Craigslist ad?
Was it?
- It was yeah.
We live in Colorado Springs and I have--
- Yeah love yeah.
- Beautiful there.
- Yeah beautiful.
- I have three kids, five grandchildren.
And I wanted a new Christmas
tree for that year.
So we went off to the store,
came home with a new tree,
and I was like "what are we
gonna do with our old tree?"
And so we decided to put it on Craigslist.
And within about an
hour we got 20 responses
that they would want our tree.
- [Kelly] Wow!
- We had one.
And so we were pretty
moved and we really wanted
to give all 20 a tree,
but we only had one.
And so that's kind of
snowballed into this project
11 years later.
- What a beautiful way that it started.
(audience clapping) You
know you were simply
just trying to be like
hey anybody need a tree?
And then you found out there
was such a need for it.
So what struck you David
about these requests?
- Well it was a couple of things.
One was the number, how quickly they came,
but I think what really touched
me they told us the stories.
I mean it was a single mom
and she told us why she was struggling.
It was a wounded vet, a
single dad raising three kids
and he just wanted a tree.
There was a boys home and
they told us some stories
about the boys home.
So many times we get tears of gratitude.
- [Kelly] I imagine.
- 'Cause one of the
things that we didn't get
before this whole thing happened
was how deeply meaningful
a Christmas tree is
and how painful it is,
especially as a parent,
if you can't give your kids a tree.
Probably one of the more
meaningful requests we got
it was from a little girl,
she was 10-years-old,
and she had a brain
injury when she was young
and she was going blind.
And so right?
And so it was a family
that had a bunch of kids
and they were kind of struggling
to deal with their medical
bills and everything else
and there was no way
they could afford a tree.
- I imagine.
- Right?
- Wow.
- So she said to her mom,
"mommy we must have a tree this year,
"it's the last one I'll ever see."
- That makes me--
- Right?
- Cry every time
I hear the story.
- I mean,
I'm gonna need a minute.
- Right right right.
- I mean what?
Oh my gosh.
So since that first Christmas
how many trees have you given?
- Over 4,000 trees.
- [Kelly] What?
- Yeah (audience claps) all
across the United States.
- Oh my gosh.
- And all around the world.
- Wow.
- And it's not
just trees though.
In my family we had a tradition
of what went on a tree.
And so we also provide
ornaments, tinsel, candy cane,
lights.
- Oh my gosh.
- [Michelle] Everything to put together
a really beautiful tree for their home.
- Oh my gosh it's so great.
(audience claps) And to like have family,
like my kids would love
to be able to do this
for other kids you know what I'm saying?
To even get like at
home like with your kids
to be like oh what can I do to like--
- I got 100 names in LA.
- Do you?
Don't you challenge me sir.
(everyone laughs)
I will--
- 100.
100--
- I am not kidding.
Like I want that list.
And I will, I literally,
I think every year
like 'cause my kids are very blessed,
I didn't grow up with like anything.
And my kids are so blessed.
And so it's one of those things
I think it's really important
no matter what household you grow up in
to always know to take
care of your neighbors
and your friends,
(audience claps)
and other people, specially
when you're so blessed.
- Okay.
- So what a fun thing to do like you know
for any mom out there or dad out there
looking to be like let's
do something with our kids
like as a family to help another family.
It's a beautiful thing.
Okay.
David and Michelle
clearly embody the message
that it's far better
to give than to receive
so in that spirit I
wanna give them something
other than the fact that I want that list
'cause I wanna help those people.
But on behalf of our show
we'd like to give your
charity 10,000 dollars.
(audience cheering)
(Kelly laughs)
- [David] Thank you.
- I think that sounds like so much fun
to be able to help people.
It's a beautiful thing.
- Thank you so much.